bueno pues lo que estamos viendo es que
con el deterioro de la situación en
ucrania que viene a puntas que siguen
saliendo por miles personas cada cada
hora sigue habiendo unas colas
kilométricas en las fronteras de algunos
países de esta gente desesperada
intentando huir son sobre todo familias
mujeres mujeres solas con los hijos
porque aquellos adultos varones de entre
18 y 60 años se tienen que quedar en
ucrania por la legislación actual y esta
situación y bueno pues las imágenes son
tremendas desgarradoras de cuando se
tiene que separar estas familias muchas
de ellas tratan de continuar viaje hacia
otros lugares de los países a los que
están llegando países que por otro lado
han abierto generosamente las fronteras
polonia hungría moldavia
rumanía dis todos los países del oeste
unos continúan hacia otras zonas de los
países otros van hacia países de la
unión europea donde tienen parientes
amigos o familiares